[Music]
[Applause]
uh coming up on the show today uh we
have comments on the upcoming show we do
we have some personal comments or a
quote yeah what is this we got a quote
we got some comments we've got some
thoughts okay
I'm sorry thoughts and prayers thoughts
and prayers uh we also have Spider-Man
updates oh tasty and Professor X
question mark who's that who that uh
we're gonna find out and get into all
that good news but first I gotta
introduce the people joining me today on
the show across the table we got Tommy
Bechtel good day mates great to see you
oh good stuff and next to him we got
Jessica Clements hello hello to YouTube
uh and I'm Brandon back who cares uh we
got a great show lined up for you today
lots to talk about
and some real late breaking news before
we hopped on uh the break room today
we're glad you're all here by the way
joining us uh in an interview with
comicbook.com Patrick Stewart who is
being interviewed about Star Trek book
card but you got to sneak in some good
Marvel questions when you got Patty yes
sitting on the chair well poor him and
Matt shackman just want to talk about
their projects and people are like what
about your Marvel stuff they want to
promote anything else but we want to
know about Marvel uh apparently Patrick
Stewart said that he was quote told to
be on standby ooh for Deadpool 3. on
standby for Deadpool 3. what if it's
just Patrick Stewart playing Patrick
Stewart well it's a very smart move if
you haven't been cast in the movie yet
kind of ironic to ask Professor X to be
on standby oh
I don't know about that one you laughed
at it I did laugh at it and then I
realized what he was saying I was
supportive and then I was I questioned
it okay uh but this is like pretty
exciting news I mean I think we all
could have guessed that maybe they'd
bring in a little Professor X for the
the Deadpool 3 uh film which of course
will feature Wolverine along with
Deadpool yes uh but what do we think
about this this news and what it could
mean for the story for that upcoming
film well I'm just glad comicbook.com is
nabbing all the big guests really
recently Eric Voss Patrick Stewart um
yeah I think that I I don't think
someone
who has been in the industry as long as
Sir Patrick Stewart
does something like that by mistake I
feel like they were like you can kind of
soft leak this very cheeky yeah like go
ahead and just like kind of be like I'm
on Standby they're not he's going to be
in the movie I think I would go ahead
and put my vagus odds at he is a he's
currently
uh even money to be in the mood even
money are we expecting him to be with
you Jackman well I mean I would hope
that Wolverine and Professor X would get
to interact in this movie right yeah
they wouldn't this wouldn't be a
different Universe where they hate each
other but it's almost Deadpool you could
be hallucinating Professor well I mean
Deadpool could dose Wolverine and he
could be getting yelled at by Patrick
Stewart who's in the face of a or he's
in a trunk of a tree like Logan I am a
tree I'm a tree uh well let's let's
dissect kind of what we know about the
fox X-Men universe as messy as it can be
uh I mean we've seen Professor X die
three times uh in movies right X-Men
Last Stand he gets evaporated by a
phoenix Force Jean Gray and then his
mind is able to put itself into a the
body of a patient yeah we see that in
the post-credits scene you hear Patrick
Stewart's voice and this comatose body
kind of turn yeah and moira's like yeah
uh so that he kind of came back and then
he shows up again in like Days of Future
Past and all that has a weird
interaction with Wolverine who's kind of
like where did you get a body from yes
I'll get evaporated he's like don't
worry about that we're gonna try to do
that with everything right it's got some
nurses back and he's right yeah well and
and Professor X says something like
you're not the only one with gifts and
it's like okay you have the gift to
reconstructure out of my spotting I
don't know I don't know and of course
famously in Logan famously we see
Patrick Stewart uh die in that film
spoiler alert if you haven't seen Logan
uh but we also know that uh it's been
confirmed from Hugh Jackman that
Deadpool 3 will take place before the
events of Logan uh he he was sure he was
there to a sure James Mangold that like
you're not going to see like the grave
of Logan and then the hand comes out and
he's alive again this will be a younger
Logan than that the Logan movie will
stand that timeline stands yeah it's not
going to get erased or anything like
that uh and then of course we've seen we
saw Professor X die in Multiverse of
Madness now that was an 838 Professor
it's a different one but but kind of
insinuated to be the wolf the ex
Professor X that we had kind of known
from the fox Universe he had the yellow
chair the green suit the green suit he
has a what he says is something that he
said to Logan uh uh or he said to
himself in Days of Future Past when he's
talking to a young person himself again
very confusing stuff with timeline shaky
in the X-Men universe and then of course
you know we had a young Professor X uh
uh played by James McAvoy in first class
and Days of Future Past and apocalypse
and uh dark Phoenix
um some of those we've forgotten about
and it's okay uh so you have all these
different Professor X's different deaths
of Professor X's yeah what do we think
they're going for here with uh returning
a Professor X to this uh Deadpool uh
Logan or Wolverine story are we not
including what we saw in Multiverse
Madness oh because I was like this is
now officially like Deadpool 3 will be a
Disney property so are we allowed to
follow up from what he we last Saw not
in the X-Men franchise the fox one but
in Multiverse and Madness sure I mean it
could be like we we've been thinking
that the TVA is going to play a role in
this movie we had Ryan Reynolds
interacting with that strange Miss
minutes account on Twitter it doesn't
seem to be official but it's not but
official people talk to it I don't know
it's very weird it's very weird uh and
you know Ryan Reynolds has kind of
hinted that like the TV is a very
interesting thing you know we had that
interview with you Jackman when he says
like Marvel has this device for time
travel now we don't know if it's a
script device or like a physical device
like you have a TVA time door or
something like that but knowing that
they're bringing Deadpool and Wolverine
into the MCU you would have to imagine
that the TVA would be interested in this
time-hopping individual yeah I also
think the relationship
between Professor X and Logan is makes
him necessary to be in this film he's
kind of the one person other than maybe
Jean Gray right that can kind of like
get through to Logan when he's really
Juiced up when he's really angry when
he's really like you know with all of
his trauma and PTSD strikes and he's and
he's like full-on Wolverine and not
Logan anymore so I think
that we could see him in kind of a
metaphysical way or like a uh possibly
as a like in his head more than anything
yeah
I think perhaps there could be that
element of it or it could be you know
something teased the entire movie by
Deadpool like some sort of like crash
joke about Wolverine and Logan and then
it pays off you know well you know what
I mean it could be a joke like it could
be a bit that's the thing with Deadpool
movies it's like you want to put all
this like weight and heft to these
storylines and it's like they could just
as usually bring in I mean they brought
Brad Pitt in to be electrocuted by power
lines right you know it's like you know
yeah yeah also he's not even there in
the second dead police riding in his
chair
right in the second Deadpool movie
Professor X
and in the Deadpool movie yeah oh yeah
because he goes he's the X-Men yeah oh
that's right
yeah sorry I was like what
yeah it was like a little joke they do
yeah so maybe yeah and Quicksilver and
and a couple of regular ones are in
there but like yeah
yeah I don't I mean I hope it's not
played for just a gag yeah me too
because you make a great Point Tommy
like Wolverine and Professor X's uh kind
of relationship is important yeah uh the
first X-Men film really established that
like uh Xavier was there to help Logan a
lot and you know we saw as they like in
Days of Future Past right Wolverine a
younger Professor X tried to talk to
Wolverine he was like get the [__] out
of here I want to talk to you right and
so it's like they he's been watching him
he's been waiting to get to him and he's
there to help him reconstruct his mind
that was like utterly devastated by
Striker right all right so it is
important and it would be seeing in
Logan how Wolverine cared so much about
Professor X even
through the awful thing that happens you
know this man aging and his powers
getting outside of his own control yeah
yeah he was still there for him he still
defended him and took care of him and
cared so much about him because he meant
so much to him so yeah I hope it's not
played Just for Laughs and it is like an
important thing I agree uh now is it
possible this is just like a whole new
Xavier it's not related to A3 wrong it's
not related to facts it's not related to
anything what if there's a nefarious
Force within the TVA that's using it to
taunt Logan by bringing in like pruned
or like or arrested variants of Charles
Xavier that they haven't pruned yeah but
they're like awaiting trout and he just
keeps like showing they just keep
pruning Xavier in front of him just just
like really stack up the death I mean
trashback said I get a super jets like
vision and Professor X competing for the
most on screen but to be fair pruning is
not death as we learned in Loki well you
just go to that other place yeah and
then if if Elia feature it I guess it is
yeah at that point then alive yeah
that's a little speech of the TVA to be
like we're not killing them yeah they
have their chance to live in this
dystopian world with a giant smoke cloud
eating them yeah it's not our fault no
uh pruning doesn't kill people yeah
Elias kills people uh I would it would
be a sweet device too if if Deadpool and
trying to reach Logan is like oh I'll go
get you a professor right yeah oh yeah
it says will Professor X die again in
Deadpool three and fifty four percent
said yeah it's pretty close if he does
see the new Sean Bean oh no if he dies
in Multiverse Madness and then dies here
I guess you if they're jumping timelines
he could just find another just keep
finding Xavier's yeah every time Logan
Gets in a bad place you gotta go find an
Xavier to bring him out of it uh but it
is very exciting news what about Ian
McKellen why aren't they calling is he
McAllen standing by I mean maybe Ian's
probably doing like Richard III uh King
Lear and like the West End and he's like
hasn't answered his phone in weeks he's
just got 50 missed calls from Kevin
feige well I mean we know Patrick
Stewart any of my calendar good friends
yeah and I bet Ian's pissed I would be
I'd be so mad if they call and then my
friend's just like did they hit you up
it's like did you get the call to play
Xavier again
I was gunned off the gray he was he was
great
as cats
um he was great in cats he was not did
he play [__] Crips
God forgot uh well we got lots more to
talk about but first we want to thank
our sponsor today Min mobile uh uh
you've heard us talk about memorable
before it's a great service uh mid
mobile was the first company to sell
premium wireless service online old only
you order from home and you save a ton
with phone plan starting at just 15
bucks a month a lot of us here at new
rockstars have made the switch to Mint
mobile it has saved us a ton of money so
much money so that we could see movies
multiple times instead of paying for our
phone calls uh it's really easy to do
it's to make the switch and all those
monthly savings they really add up mint
mobile offers premium wireless service
for just 15 bucks a month Yeah by going
online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you and
these plans are they're good plans
they're Unlimited [__] text their
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network and if you
already have a phone you love you don't
got to get rid of it you keep your phone
you keep your contacts you keep your
number so you don't have to give a new
number that's all those ladies and
gentlemen out here you've been sharing
your number two be careful out there uh
but you can switch cement mobile and get
premium wireless service again starting
at just 15 a month Brandon I got to make
a quick disclaimer to everybody give
them a disclaimer do not put your mint
mobile phone in your mouth to try to
freshen your brain oh it's not that the
name is minty fresh the phones remain
disgusting germ sponges that will simply
make the reason I have a stuffy nose is
I soaked my mint mobile phone in my
mouth for about an hour and a half yeah
you thought it would freshen you and I
caught some kind of plague so well well
the plan is fresh
the taste of the phone remains
disgusting and I I learned I'm sorry to
hear that Tommy well don't do what Tommy
did uh don't put a phone in your mouth
but switch to Mint mobile get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free just go to memmobile.com break
room that's eventmobile.com breakroom
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
good gracious phone is Bodacious
speaking of Bodacious is my part it's
the headline yeah
headlines crazy thank you
I don't know how to do improv anymore so
I waited you did like the Disney Channel
welcome here to the break room
I drew people we all did a bad job
Amazon Prime video oh I'm sorry Amazon
Prime video and Sony I've announced a
live action Spider-Man Noir series live
action live action baby black and white
live action we saw it we loved it and
um
um Disney into the spider-verse knows uh
Sin City
um
I'm just naming everything I've seen in
black and white the artist Frankenstein
um it's uh Phil Lord Wizard of Oz for
part of it
we'll learn Amy Pascal our all executive
producers on the show as well as Oren
uzo Izzo who will also join and write
and has previously written on John Wick
4 and Mortal Kombat so this is gonna
have a lot of choreography yeah yes yes
this is the second project announced by
uh of the Amazon and Sony Spider-Man
collaborations with the other being
spider silk Society with showrunner
Angela Kang and here's hoping Nicholas
Cage will star in this oh my God
after the across the spider-verse just
came out everyone was so sad to not have
like spider Noir and missing a couple
more and it's like why do they want to
focus on this can I make a suggestion if
Nicholas Cage is unavailable do it
Nathan Fillion oh that's okay do you
think he can do the Mortal Kombat John
Wick uh like like choreography he's
gotten in shape before yeah you put a
spider mask on people anyone yeah yeah
exactly yeah I mean come on it's like V
for Vendetta you think Hugo leaving was
in there daggering people I mean I I was
really excited loved Spider-Man spider
Noir uh in into the spider-verse and
yeah they haven't announced him for a
crisis spider-verse or any of the other
characters except Peter B Parker yeah I
think they're saving him I think they
don't want to spoil it also if it's
going to be a sweet moment when they
show up yes it's also yes and it's
across the spider verse so if this is a
team up thing it's like watch them show
up a little bit and across the
spider-verse go into this live action
series
[Music]
yeah but he's also alive he's also a
liar he also bought a T-rex skull yeah
but he gave it back he gave it back he
gave it back when he heard it he took my
skull he lost the money on that one uh I
was a bad investment
it'll be an interesting show to be in
live action I hope it's super stylized
and I don't I haven't read spider Noir
Comics does he ever take his mask off
does he Crush thing
huh Tommy what Tommy I use a hard-boiled
detective Thomas it's a reasonable
question next headline we gotta we got a
quote about the upcoming Echo Show from
Stephen Broussard uh when speaking with
the collider he said it's a very
different tonal sort of thing I don't
want to say too much because there's not
a whole lot out there in the world but
it feels very grounded it feels very
spiritual in ways that feel fresh for us
uh what is this is the lead is
incredibly compelling I'm sort of
hard-pressed to think of something that
it feels like outside in the broader
Realm of the MCU let alone within what
we've done here can you scroll back up a
little bit he said I want to see it
feels very spiritual in ways that feel
fresh for us yeah what does that mean I
I take it to be like a totally new show
a new approach you know I think in a lot
of the ways like a film uh like black
panther by Panther what kind of forever
comes from like a totally different
voice a different person yes yes very
different from everything else I I uh
one of my favorite film terms of phase
four shanxi yes in the legend of the ten
Rings felt so different than a lot of
the the Marvel movies we've seen were
they're all they're great and but you're
like I get the formula I see that's true
like I had a whole different perspective
uh and I like that I also like this
answer because this is the type of
answer I give at work when someone asks
me about a project I have not worked on
yeah I'm like oh I can't say too much
you did a really good job
uh how do you feel about Eric Ross's
Ant-Man Quantum media breakdown oh it's
so great I mean there's so many things
going on with that and it's very special
to us it's a breakdown we haven't done
things I gotta say and this is no knock
against her whatever a Lockwood did on
that set has every sound bite is like
she's incredible yeah and I don't know I
don't mean that cynically no the her
performance in this must be unbelievable
because it is in every single quote I
mean what do you mean oh and oh like
they talk about her performance
and her co-stars are just like she's
incredible so yeah whatever she brings
to this character which was pretty and
probably one of the highlights of how
Hawkeye to be honest I'm excited for it
yeah I am too the show was like pushed
back a little bit as far as its release
date but yeah everyone's been very very
careful to say like oh the the show's
Grant we love the direction it's going
and that do you think the delay was to
have it come out closer to uh Daredevil
I was thinking about that I was like
what is didn't we get a little piece of
info of what the actual delay was
because I was like was it because
they're trying to get closer to Deadpool
because then they moved Deadpool another
series or double sorry they moved
another series to uh Daredevil comes
first now before another series they've
kind of messed around with this series
and I think that's a result of as
stories change in movies and they make
little tweaks and different cameos and
availability of actors because these
things are so connected sure when one
thing changes like it has these yeah
that affect everything uh that is very
hopefully it's all for the best that is
very true next headline even if you're
promoting another property you can never
avoid those Marvel questions while doing
interviews for Amazon Prime crimes the
consultant series Matt shankman Jackman
compared the Fantastic Four to Star Trek
that's what I'm looking at you he said
they share a great sense of optimism the
idea of looking to the stars in
technology can save everything and come
to and coming together as a family
either a real family or the family that
you find the Enterprise
oh my God it's an interesting comparison
that's such a weird comparison well no
it's not because I guess they are a team
of different people built like on this
one ship in the middle of space they're
like you know there's some family
there's some like I'm just your friend
I'm your brother well that's why I'm
like they become a family but then
they're forced to be together because
now they're all weird your chosen family
yes
you know I do want to bring up the
consultant uh I auditioned for that oh
yeah how'd it go I turned it down and
ultimately because it was a full frontal
roll with only one line so sorry to say
watch the consultant you'll see 100 less
Tom dong damn where do we find Tom Don
uh you can find that on my only fan
which right now is currently being
rented by a man named Caleb this month
oh okay but it'll be available in March
nice
uh previously shackman was attached to
direct Star Trek film before stepping
away to do the Fantastic Four as well
yeah maybe she said Star Trek on his
mind yeah he's like Star friend maybe he
like had a really good script for Star
Trek and he's like oh I had a great idea
for a fantastic board this family will
be on a spaceship yeah
swing the Scrolls yeah yeah they've
never got before or you know what he
might be doing if he waits long enough
Direct's Fantastic Four he's like it
might become for a total Star Trek
reboot and then I could just go in and
be like let's start this thing from the
ground up let's start all over again
Matt shackman free advice next headline
Bob Iger announced Disney would be
targeting three billion in content cost
savings oh my goodness God damn planning
to eliminate 7 000 positions to Aid in
doing so he plans to reorganize the
company into three Core Business
segments Disney entertainment ESPN
Disney Parks that's more than one Disney
Parks experiences
experiences and products so all three
segment the three Core Business segments
are Disney entertainment ESPN Disney
Parks experiences and products and ESPN
famously you know a couple years ago had
massive layoffs they laid off a ton of
their uh remote like this is our
reporter in the San Francisco area that
covers the Giants 49ers I mean I
remember on Twitter that day it was like
nuclear Monday like yeah it was all
these like all these people you know I
watch a ton of sports content and it was
all of them doing their like hey a bit
of news I've been I've been letting no
uh I've been notified that I've been let
go of ESPN and since then the
subscriptions ESPN plus which we talked
about are part of the bundling and
everything they have grown from like 2
million to 23 million subscribers a
month part of that really nice
affordable package that gets you Hulu
Disney plus and ESPN but I also think
they've made some smart moves that have
maybe it's been one of the more
profitable wings of Disney so it makes
sense and you can also
you could probably shift some of the
Disney things over into the world of
ESPN like you know some of their
Productions could be especially with
their like docu-series High School
Musical they play basketball on that but
I'm thinking Mighty Ducks the next the
next Wing or whatever
uh double teamed is that you're is that
your movie I don't think anyone don't
think we're talking about the same level
today okay uh this was some of my very
interesting kind of kind of industry
news right and what does this mean like
cutting it from the content because they
were like they're not cutting it from
Disney Parks they're like they're doing
great we're fine yeah I mean there's a
lot going on here this was part of an
Investor's call yesterday which is like
always a big deal and this is kind of
where you get a sense where the company
is going we're seeing this a lot too in
multiple Industries where as the world
shifts back to a more the work style we
had previously before the pandemic
positions change and they're like well
we don't need this segment anymore also
when they talk about like the layoffs
right when they say like oh we're gonna
eliminate like 7 000 positions a lot of
those positions might not even be filled
yeah because they have been in a hiring
freeze under shapewrack they did that
yeah and so if you eliminate a job if
you had a job posting and you eliminated
it that counts as like an eliminated
position even though no one was there
that one person with that job
the sexy headline is that they're going
to get rid of seven thousand jobs right
right yeah yeah yeah and a lot of this
is tied to uh Disney plus around the
world yeah I was like is this
International yeah actually they've had
some ups and downs like Disney hot star
Disney plus hot star which is the what
they have in India they lost their
rights to like cricket and so I think a
lot of people dropped it guys
yeah yeah so what happens to like places
like Hulu that just has like a good
chunk well they have said so Disney
Disney owns part of Hulu with like
comments with everybody else yeah that's
what they did early on uh when streaming
was just getting started right uh I I
indicated they'd be willing to like sell
off their part their share now instead
of buying out Comcast being like we'll
sell off our problems that's interesting
because then what happens to FX FX has
been pretty much relegated to Hulu Plus
they've put a lot of their movies that
they've decided not to release
theatrically I wonder oh yeah
do for yeah but can you put like can you
put like
a a supernatural horror could you put
prey on Disney plus I I well I mean we
we've talked about before as they get
closer to adding they added like a tvma
category to Disney plus and they added
like parental controls it could be
getting there hey maybe you at home have
an idea for how to fix this message plus
late night so you're telling me they're
gonna put Archer on Disney plus maybe I
don't know send your ideas to Bob dot
Iger at disney.com he'd love to hear
what you think about and remember
shaking things up we're always streaming
live on thrust
TV my streaming network uh this is very
interesting though when we talk about
like how these kind of changes will
affect what's on Disney plus right do we
uh do should we be worried about like
Marvel and Star Wars uh do you think
they'll they could be affected by these
Cuts because well we get and or season
two no those are money makers and or
season 2 has already started production
I don't think we're going to see a
Warner Brothers like scrapping of entire
projects I just don't think is Bob Iger
wanted to cut something like that well
not like and or where they already
started shooting but farther
but like would they put something else
on pause because it's like they already
have like four Star Wars properties
already like loaded but they haven't
come out yet well John made the good
point that like if you scrap something
that's already been shot like that's a
three years away savings right so it's
like it's something like armor war is in
trouble you know where it's like it's
been shifted from a TV show to a movie
and now it's like maybe it's just not
going to come out you know like they
could they they could save ostensibly
250 million dollars from not doing armor
Awards yeah right well I don't think
they're not going to just not put it out
but I do think but it's not still right
like armor says it's not even started
production yet I feel like we talked
about something along a headlines for
this because for some reason I'm so
convinced that Marvel is staying where
it is but there's something in Star Wars
that was being like altered either them
like pausing something oh Rogue Squadron
right was like right that's always been
rumored to happen and then it was like
not gonna happen and they're like no
it's still happening and then Patty
Jenkins kind of put in her like I'm
doing fine thing didn't she mention like
I'm working on a right Squadron right
now yeah I would think Disney would be
hesitant to like cut stuff that they've
announced yeah because you know we did
see Warner Brothers and do that with
some stuff including DC stuff and it's
like I'm sure Disney's like well we're
not there is there things they can even
take off of Hulu I wonder well if they
because they probably need Comcast
Comcast uh
uh well the only things we really have
on Hulu are like all the Fox right
ABC I was like they make so much money
off of Bob's Burgers and the other Fox
I'm just trying to figure out like of
all their wings on Disney plus there's
like what is it there's uh National
Geographic right like could they start
removing stuff from Daddy G I don't know
sorry no Limitless season two from from
Chris Hemsworth I didn't like lemon oh
are we talking about the show yeah yeah
I don't like that what about renovations
I don't know I don't know I mean the the
new the new series from Marvel were
still kind of like we don't have dates
for them yeah right it's been really
slow uh we don't even know when what if
season two is coming we don't know when
secret invasion is is supposed to debut
right and that's coming in the spring of
this year they've told us well I think
those things are still coming but
holding on them is probably a good idea
if you guys are like I don't want to
lose any more money and it's not like
losing money in like what it reviews
it's losing money as in we're putting a
lot of stuff out animation's expensive
and then we also have a bunch of movies
right well they also announced like we
said yesterday all of these sequels
which we'll get to later on in the show
but like it's like oh yeah they're
making yeah Toy Story what is this Toy
Story five yeah and Frozen three which
Frozen three seems like a no-brainer Toy
Story 5 to me is confusing because Toy
Story 4 I mean I hate to say for
anything that's a cartoon ended on a
pretty final note like it was like but I
guess you know as long as there's toys
in the world there's always stories told
and always children to be I think Toy
Story 4 was the end of winning Woody's
story what is gone you don't think he's
going to be in the movie no he is it's
gonna be
him nope it's gonna be him before
so much money and Beau ran off to go you
think Woody's Forkey in both smack smack
smooth surfaces but do you think that's
the reason there's a snake in my bow
long term they're probably uh planning
on making these sequels but do you think
jumping to make these sequels
immediately is so they can get more
money the 7 000 people laid off but then
they're coming out with a frozen three
potentially and all those those sequels
they announced they'll be in theaters
it's not funny yeah and those were like
actually I and this we can talk about
later because I'm like they chose Toy
Story and Frozen two very popular ones
and then they chose zootopia which I
think is an odd one Utopia zootopia
called zootopia doesn't it have a
different name in uh it does overseas it
does it's called the zoo
we call it zoopalistic sorry I think
also like a lot of these Cuts we could
see episode counts go down right yeah I
mean they've announced the big ones for
like Daredevils from the future they
might be cutting down and again we might
not see the effects of these cuts for
years I mean it's all the stuff that
they've planned out is probably still
going to come out would you be mad if
they made like a dynamite four-part kind
of mini-series out of a title right like
somewhere between a special presentation
I would always want more sure but leave
them wanting more yeah and it's like a
good improv show it's three and a half
hours long and then there's a great joke
at the end yeah yeah uh but this could
be interesting if it's busy if Disney's
on the ropes right now like this could
be a chance for DC to come in now they
still got to get through this year
because all of these like planned new
things for for DC aren't coming until
2024 at least at the first so we'll have
to see and you know I I would argue DC
hasn't had as many like big hits yeah
that like uh Marvel has had obviously I
mean fans really like the Batman right
uh Joker did well won some Oscars right
and the suicide squad was a marked
improvement for sure Squad again though
that would didn't have a big box office
because we were still in kind of a
pandemic times well it didn't even get
it yeah
yeah yeah and surprisingly Aquaman was
one of the highest grossers of Jason
Momoa which is crazy
Wilson effect a lot of people were like
oh Aquaman was like fun and a little
more bright yeah than the typical sniper
stuff my mom saw Aquaman like three
times her Jason Momoa in his jeans Jason
Momoa we'll get that Aquaman is there
any room for Linda
not my mom not my mom I mean of course
you know like
I'm gonna clip this in the door uh James
gun you know like your new slate and it
does look really attractive it does that
start until 2024. but we're gonna have
like the regular stuff and all the
elseworld projects coming in there maybe
Constantine two off the table on the
table we never know uh and then
apparently the flash is amazing yeah uh
there's all these rumors uh they're
saying it's great uh but I don't know
you know we'll have to see how the flash
does and if it is a big hit for them uh
James Gunn has clarified the
relationship between DC Studios and
Warner Brothers he was responding to a
fan on Instagram loves to take to social
media yeah and he said quote DC is
separate from Warner Brothers as of a
couple months ago what does that mean
I don't think they're actually like
separated but he's like I'm doing my own
business he doesn't have to answer to
any Warner Brothers people he only
answer to Warner Discovery executive you
know what I mean like it might be that
like the pools of money are separate
sure Warner Brothers having trouble it's
not their job yeah yeah they're not
going to cut another they're not going
to cut super girl World of Tomorrow got
it uh if the next uh you know Discovery
show does that's interesting that seems
like a big gamble on James Gunn but I
like it you know I mean I think it's
their best chance I think he'll put his
money in there's always more Matrix
films to make always more and I will
watch them they'll be like Kiana you
can't make that Constantine two until we
get three we're not making billing ten
three until you go back into the Matrix
uh uh we got a super chat from DJ cold
cuts who said The only Cuts I'm worried
about is cold cuts DJ Cool Kids you love
cold cuts my name is DJ Cool Cuts trash
bag also noting that Tom dong is my
favorite category on thrust TV yes all
right
we actually have we've seen a noted gain
in subscribers most of which are
government agents looking for reasons to
prosecute but we uh we actually turned a
profit it's tax season so I hope you get
a reason yeah we turned a profit last
year and by that I mean we we became a
prophet we started predicting religious
and biblical events on my new show the
future on thrust TV on thrust
but I think I think this would be good
for both companies competition is
competition's great both both Studios
having to stay on their game to earn the
fans hard-earned dollars at the movie
theater which is only getting more
expensive right the actual experience is
now basically like going to a sporting
event right like I mean it really is
concessions and if tickets are 20 bucks
that's you know major league baseball
game is like 30 but like you know
consent with concessions feeding
everybody you're in over 100 bucks
either way point being uh the the two
the two entities being robust and
healthy uh only leads to to us all
winning and there's another way to win
and that's Factor oh okay what's Factor
there's nothing worse than wrapping up a
long day at work I'm going to face a
long night of cooking dinner pee you
save time and energy with factors ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door and if you don't have a door if you
live in a garbage dump oh just let them
knock
toss the meals over and they will gift
Factor eat it raw not only skip the trip
to the grocery store but skip the
chopping prepping cleaning up too
Factor's fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes that's a
long time for me so all you have to do
is heat and enjoy factorized meals that
are keto oh you looking for calorie
smart yeah you're looking for vegan and
veggie oh yeah how about full of protein
100 well guess what they have them all
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all of the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long baby Factor meals have all
the ingredients you want and nothing you
don't you're looking for baloney you're
not going to find it maybe you will with
35 34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options there's always something
new to try plus you can round out your
meal and replenish your snack Supply
with an assortment of quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons quick bite oh my get factor and
enjoy clean eating without the hassle
simply choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor-packed meals delivered to your
door already in just two minutes there
really is no easier way to eat well and
trust me I love eating well how do we
get it well there's only one way Jessica
you got to contact me the dog
head over to factormeals.com break room
50. that's right there up on the screen
use code break room 50 to get 50 off
your first box that's code break room 50
at factorymeals.com break room 50 to get
50 off your first box I said this before
I cannot stress it if you are a person
that is very bad about eating you throw
that bad boy in the microwave and you
have to eat it and it's good for you and
you can get it the way you want I do
love those the the when they drop off
the fresh you just got our microwave
meals that type of service you know
we're all it's Factor February so I
don't mean the harp on factor you've got
your money's worth but I'll keep talking
Factor February it's going to be Factor
March because we slacked off in the
first week of factor February Super Bowl
Sunday is certainly going to be a factor
on my waistline so Factor February Will
Rain Supreme into factored March and
hell I'm looking at a factor April as
well now
Jenny Davis
twenty dollars yeah they said in a hot
Super Chat this might be a little
industry a little industry Insider uh
Jenny Davis says they're an ex-warner
Brothers employee and they claim that DC
used to be under Warner Brothers Studio
they're for Warner Brothers made all the
decisions they were the bus the brothers
Warner they were now the Warner's sister
died oh that's true uh now DC is under
parent company Warner Brothers Discovery
and is reporting to zaz labs and his
directs so then what they have to do is
they have to pour all the Ooze into
zazlov's mold so he can rise up yeah
what should I cancel today all right
it's time for mandatory oh no mandatory
boy guess what everybody we talked
earlier about all those sweet sweet
sequels that have been greenlit by Bob
Iger Frozen three
Toy Story five right zootopia zootopia
too Utopia please call zootopia well
guess what
I've given you guys each an assignment
oh yeah come up with a sequel that
didn't get green lit but deserves a
chance
and we'll decide maybe the viewers will
decide if we can green light these oh
okay Disney plus okay sequels you want
me to go first yeah you go first mine my
pitch my pitch this is a great pitch and
I think they should do it holes two
who's digging me oh
it sounds very off
I need to know okay no no no no it's
about everybody else that was in the
camp and I'm talking zero and I'm
talking armpit and I'm talking extra I'm
talking all of them and it's them as
adults now and they don't know how to
find love anymore because they've been
all grown up in that little Camp digging
holes their entire life and now they
finally got out and they're like we want
Partners we want relationships and it's
their trials and tribulations finding
love holes to who's digging me oh my oh
okay maybe the title can be reworked I
like that dig them up
[Music]
yeah this song is done by Ariana Grande
and uh
and the weekend
with you okay uh Brandon what do you got
first uh here's what I got I'm gonna I
wanna see a sequel to one of my uh
favorite of them the modern Disney era I
would say uh this would be called
Tangled two
Gentlemen Prefer blinds whoa take them
out there
we're 13 years out uh from the events of
of the first time okay uh Flynn you
might also know him as Eugene they're
married to Rapunzel it's been 13 years
yeah marriage is getting a little stale
so they're in the castle the people of
Corona they're tired of being under a
monarchy they want to upload the system
Rapunzel's pissed about that yeah you
got two kids they're turning into real
[__] time to bring in a third like a
third kid throw it into the bedroom oh
well I don't know because like you know
uh it's getting real pissed yeah he's
tired he's also mad that Rapunzel's
blonde hair
his horse died of old age the Maximus is
still alive okay yeah uh and and you
know the in-laws Rapunzel's parents they
don't really get Rapunzel because they
didn't raise her she's got different
morals and stuff yeah they're not
getting along and they don't like Flynn
he's a criminal yeah he's a bit of a
drunkard you know he likes to drink a
lot and he's got some questionable views
we've got questionable views he doesn't
like the fact that everyone's got to
take the flower now he says we shouldn't
force people to take the flower anymore
okay agree heavily so flammy wants to
have a little a boys weekend see what's
still out there you know maybe get the
tip of his Arrow away
him and Maximus Pascal they go out and
they have like a hangover style
Adventure they hit up the snuggly
duckling oh my God have a good weekend
out there sure you know maybe it ends
happy maybe it doesn't I don't know I
just picture like uh uh one of one of
Flynn's friends being calling Rapunzel
and being like we effed up we lost him
we lost Flint uh that's great uh I love
both of these ideas I have one too and
then we have some uh rapid fire ones
that we'll try and do from memory I uh I
got a couple I want you to imagine
you're sliding a VHS tape in it's the
year it's 1992. I don't know what that
is I was born you're hearing the music
[Music]
you know the VHS music oh okay and then
you get coming soon from Disney pictures
the circus has come to town and Dumbo is
the star of the show that is until Lloyd
rolls in is there room enough for two
elephants under the big top find out
when these two friends who are elephants
who always forget team up for dumb and
dumboer he's an elephant that has ears
so big he can fly he's an elephant that
shoots peanuts out his nose like a
Russian anti-aircraft gun what kind of
trouble are these two gonna get into it
dumb and dumboer then you cut to a rat
holding one of those racist crows that's
how it's been ripped off pretty bird
pretty bird oh cute in theaters
Halloween day is this live-action Dumbo
or animated it's actually a hybrid oh
okay expensive
we had some uh we had some honorary
mentions uh we had two Bed Knob two
broomsticks that's a way to take the
Fast and Furious franchise into the
Disney World I would love that they
really miss the chance of it just lost
Angela because like we could have had
her we could have had I know but I could
I could take over it uh uh
Financial wednesbury
I like crumb cakes and teas off to bed
now Chip time for your bedtime uh I like
the sequel to Wally Wally uh Wall Street
Wally Wall Street money never bleeps
um oh I like
um a little a little growing up in the
hood uh a version to Sleeping Beauty and
it's called Napoli oh you need about it
and that's what that's what she keeps
going to sleep without a bonnet and
they're like eight I also see it so
pillowcases I also pitched a jungle
cruise but Tommy came up with a better
name for it jungle cruising yeah jungle
cruising which could be a fight but I
wanted to be I wanted to be a gay cruise
line you're on the jungle cruise looking
out for uh for for your mates I also
think perhaps it's time to take uh our
favorite little chipmunks into a little
more spicy territory so I present to you
Chippendales risque dancers no no how
dare you I'm gonna say no
the curse of the courtroom oh God I'll
take a mega pint of wine oh my God it
took me a minute
there's a starting kid in play oh
and play didn't you have an idea for a
disenchanted and Enchanted sequel oh
yeah you have disenchanted you had
Enchanted yeah disenchanted now we need
to do re-enchanting yes you bring back
all the people from the town I like the
other one you fish too
disenfranchisement
yeah we can't afford it will you turn on
the you turn it on that episode and then
you just get immediately logged out
these are all fantastic I'd green light
anyways guys put in the chat uh whatever
you if you have an idea for something
that needs to be simplified that's a
Disney property I'm giving you guys a
Time green lightning oh I love it yeah I
I love that I briefly looked at our
reflection and I look like Linda Belcher
oh my God Bobby now uh okay I want to
mention before we leave yes please Eric
Voss and I what we'll be together who in
person no February 11th that's only
married two days away a kybercon 2023.
oh you can go to kybercave.com
k-y-d-e-r-c-a-v-e.com to buy your
tickets in advance to save a few bucks
Eric and I will be there as well as John
D Michaels an actor from squid game
Ellen Fernandez who was an original
Tuscan Raider in a new home and Joshua
Pila who is I mean
He is unbelievable he does like flow
dancing with lightsabers it's like
choreographer he can make the saber like
slide up and down his entire body it's
really sounds risque it's impressive
it's very impressive now this is in
Fairfield California which I believe is
in the Bay Area uh there will be a
costume contest come get dressed up Eric
and I are going to do two different
panels one is just the two of us talking
about our creative process the other is
a larger question q a panel with with
all of the guests uh come and see us
take a picture you know give me a high
five I could use it guys my self-esteem
hasn't been the best lately so meet me
at kybercon 2023 I hope to see you there
hit him with that website again that is
kybercave.com for advanced sales ten
dollars
and it's a whole thing there's vendors
someone's probably doing balloon animals
I don't know if not bring balloons I'll
make an animal I lost to Gentlemen
Prefer blonde people want to see Flynn
to his I think we've dumb and dumbor
which by the way shout out to Whitney
van laningham who came up with that idea
uh didn't get better didn't get a better
result uh shame on you we also sent out
two Bing bongs back at Corey can't
really we're not breaking off they are
making an inside out too
well
I think they should change it anyway
she's a teenager she needs to have a
different a couple more different
emotions oh my God if I had an inside
out when I was a teenager it would just
be one guy screaming
is that what he's screaming
cheeseburger oh
uh
the Phoenix also said in a super chat
about our earlier discussion uh
suggesting what if Deadpool goes on his
own Time Heist and gathers all the
Infinity Stones of Wolverine and uses
them to snap himself the thing is I
wouldn't be surprised if he does that
like he did in uh the second Deadpool
once he's just jumping time he's like I
got up stones and he just jumps into the
MCU I would not be surprised at that I I
would love to see it I I would love to
see it uh if if the result of it is that
like the other universes are destroyed
he ultimately destroys the Fox
University he's like whoopsies yes
oopsies I like it uh uh we also want to
remind you guys a few programming
announcements right uh if if you know
we've been covering the last of us here
on the channel part of our after show on
the break room uh this week they're
airing the last of us tomorrow night
instead of on Sunday because of the
Super Bowl uh so we'll have our after
show The Last of Us after show we won't
be live tomorrow at three we'll be on in
the evening with our after show for
episode five of the last Last of Us you
got time to catch up if you haven't been
watching the show uh grab a box of
tissues and watch the show get all
caught up on episode five uh and join us
for the after show and then Sunday after
the Super Bowl record won't be live
we're having a little Super Bowl party
here Super Bowl party gotta be lots of
hot trailers in the Super Bowl and hot
dips I hope you're taking a dip hot
wings and hot people and hot chicks uh
uh so yeah there's gonna be so many
trailers and we can't wait to talk about
them so we're gonna go live after the
Super Bowl so tune in for that you can
still watch the big game I'll be I'm
gonna dress up as a football player oh
yeah yes which one cute
yeah Josh Allen Josh Allen I'll dress up
as Josh Allen uh also on the channel be
sure to check be sure to check out uh
Jessica's read breakdown of black
panther wakanda forever tons of great
new stuff she found in there uh and lots
of stuff from the creators of the film
Tommy's been uh wrapping up the the bad
batch on the channel been doing the Lord
live now check that out uh and then
tomorrow we're getting a fast 10 uh
trailer in the morning and for some
strange reason the powers that be of
assigned Whitney and I to do it we're so
excited gonna cover it let's see how far
two people with horrific ADHD can go off
the chain of what is in the trailer well
luckily there's no other shoots tomorrow
we can be here for hours and then I'll
be driving to Fairfield California right
after Fairfax that's right uh thank you
all for joining us today we hope you had
a great Thursday we can't wait to see
you here on the channel tomorrow enjoy
the rest of your Thursdays uh like And
subscribe thanks so much for watching
we'll check you out soon late Escape
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign